ladies and gentlemen please welcome His
Highness Sheikh Mohammed bin Rashid Al
Maktoum vice president and prime
minister of the UAE and ruler of Dubai
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
your highness
distinguished guests ladies and
gentlemen please welcome her Excellency
Reem al-hashimi Minister of State for
International Cooperation chairperson of
Dubai Cares and director-general of Expo
2020
[Music]
smilla rahmanir rahim' good evening and
welcome your excellencies to the 2018
global teacher prize welcome and thank
you especially to His Highness Sheikh
Mohammed bin Rashid Al Maktoum vice
president and prime minister of the
United Arab Emirates and ruler of Dubai
for your patronage of the Varkey
foundation's global teacher prize and
for your tireless global efforts to
create a better world for all of us may
we please also give a special hand of
applause to sunny Varkey and to the
Varkey foundation for bringing for
bringing global education together
tonight it is wonderful to be here with
so many of you as we reach a pinnacle of
another successful year of teachers
accomplishments tonight we celebrate the
global teacher prize in the year of
Zayed by paying tribute to a special
commitment captivated by the
extraordinary responsibility of teachers
who dedicate their life's cause to
others as a great service to society
that we've seen in chef Zayed who was
not just the founder of the United Arab
Emirates and a great leader but he was
also a great teacher in my work as
Minister of State for International
Cooperation I traveled to all parts of
the world and in these journeys I've
been privileged to meet people from all
walks of life from sub-saharan Africa to
the Caribbean island to the Pacific to
South America everywhere I go and no
matter what we discuss education is
always a central element of every single
conversation it is through education
that societies transform and what
transforms a child's education
the teacher of course teachers in effect
can change the world they represent the
best values in our society they show
commitment and resilience as they enter
their classrooms every day and teach
often times despite the availability of
adequate materials and support they
bring patience and creativity as they
find a way for children to understand
our world and how to be a part of it
and I must recognize those teachers that
show kindness and perseverance to ensure
that children with determination and
children with special needs are never
left behind
[Applause]
stemming from this strong belief last
month the united arab emirates pledged a
hundred million dollars to the global
partnership for education demonstrating
its commitment to the monumental task of
ensuring a quality education for all
children and ladies and gentlemen there
is no quality education without quality
teachers
when we were all children we looked to
our mothers and to our fathers and to
teachers as superheroes who showed us
the way and taught us how to walk or fly
through life without teachers harnessing
our ability to expand our minds our past
would be our present and our future
would be our past thank you to every
single teacher around the world for
advancing education and improving our
ability to learn great teachers provide
hope for tomorrow
they provide purpose and strength and
community there should not be a single
child in our world whose only daily
mission is to find their next meal
instead all children should have as a
basic human right access to books
classrooms and teachers so that every
person may have opportunities and the
mobility to contribute to our global
society whether you are blessed as a
preschool teacher who provides
fundamentals a history teacher who helps
us understand our role in life a teacher
who seeks adversity to transform
communities or one who inspires students
to make dreams a reality through
emerging technology you are all heroes
and our world is a better place because
of you good luck to tonight's global
teacher prize finalists and
congratulations to all the nominees and
teachers around the world for your
humanity you are certainly all winners
thank you for your time and attention
have a lovely evening everyone
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
your excellency ladies and gentlemen
please show your appreciation for our
national teacher prize representatives
[Music]
thank you your ex
[Music]
ladies and gentlemen now a message from
the President of Argentina your highness
your excellencies ladies and gentlemen
our Salam alaykoum good evening and
congratulations on a sixth edition of
the Global Education and Skills forum
quality education is the key to a life
of fulfillment and independence and it
shouldn't have a single boundary gender
culture ethnicity and macron shouldn't
stand in anyone's way this year marks
the 10th anniversary of the g20 summit
and Argentina has the privilege of
holding its presidency we need to work
together renewing our commitment to
leave no one behind
and this means ensuring every child has
access to an education that prepares him
or her for the challenges ahead this
will be one of the main goals of this
year's g20 summit as we build consensus
for firm and sustainable development the
thing of our presidency good luck to
this year's finalists for the global
teaching prize
[Applause]
your highness
distinguished guests ladies and
gentlemen please welcome your host for
this evening mr. Trevor Noah
[Music]
no Highness excellencies ladies and
gentlemen good evening and welcome to
the 2018 global teacher prize award
ceremony welcome to it this is it it's
been a long time coming good to see you
again this is an amazing evening ladies
and gentlemen where we celebrate a
fantastic achievement by teachers from
all over the world and it is an honor to
host this outstanding event and in
particular to be able to do so in the
year of Zayed marking the 100th
anniversary of the birth of a visionary
leader who made all of this possible
thank you so much now this year's
ceremony also concludes the most
ambitious and largest global Education
and Skills forum yet now in its fourth
year the global teacher prize was set up
to shine a spotlight on great teachers
all over the world by unearthing
thousands of heroes and thousands of
stories of young people's lives that are
being transformed every single day the
prize highlights their exceptional work
that might otherwise go unnoticed their
students go on to win Nobel Peace Prizes
and the Oscars and the Grammys and so it
only seems fitting that these teachers
get a reward of their own
tonight's teachers will be getting the
kind of global media and attention and
glittering ceremony that's usually only
reserved for Hollywood royalty and
nobility being a teacher today is more
difficult than ever before ladies and
gentlemen you have to prepare young
children for all the challenges of life
you have to prepare them for a world
that is constantly changing and let's be
honest every single person in this room
if it weren't for teachers we wouldn't
be here my teachers taught me to read my
best teachers taught me how to think
critically and if I didn't know how to
read and I didn't know how to think then
what future would I have nothing I mean
maybe I could become presidents of the
United States but nothing else
so thank you to our teachers only
through teachers can we give young
people the kind of advanced skills that
can never be replaced by artificial
intelligence only through teachers will
young people understand how new
technologies can be applied to alleviate
the world's problems and deep-seated
issues and only through teachers can we
give young people the wisdom to use
their technology wisely so ladies and
gentlemen we are lucky and absolutely
honored to have ten remarkable teachers
here with us today ladies and gentlemen
please welcome the finalists for the
global teacher prize of 2018
[Applause]
[Music]
in my classes I focus on 21st century
skills but it's our task to create
innovators and digital learners and the
digital leaders my dream for the
students who might teach and people
around the world who are getting to
watch my videos is that they learn to
understand mathematics is a beautiful
thing I found out from day one that this
is something that was gonna do for the
rest of my life I want all of my
students to understand that through hard
work perseverance grit that they can be
successful at anything they want to
accomplish culture based teaching is
really keeping the children to stay in
school if it's only with the awareness
of our identity that that empowers us
when we are empowered we can become
productive citizens of our community of
the country and of the world I teach art
and textiles and they are powerful
subjects that helps the students and not
all of their language barriers I
absolutely love what I do I can't
imagine having any other job LPC pareto
inin Cassio is cambiar la Montagna de
toda unity Miroslav join senior for
kidding me experience a personal in
docent the symphony from o la vida he is
lucky to zero as economist I wanted to
make learning global I want to reach
more children by connecting students
around the world I hope that they will
be inspired by each other most of all
enjoy learning
okay medium eyes okay nose nice Cola a
cuando ellos albums
deshan do mundo cream does Gragas a
busker nights : assist students in
Mahmood rgvida on our bidding we would
be on the GDG Vega detective Aidan
little bit further the hi begin each day
for the Navy mixture sided to do -
stream up to Jeremiah so da cunha is on
an asymmetrical omelet South Africa is a
country of great inequality and I
believe that literacy is the key to
leveling the playing field I teach to
educate people well beyond the classroom
to build tolerance democracy and future
leaders
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
keep it going one more time ladies and
gentlemen for this year's ten amazing
finalists
[Applause]
[Applause]
all right
I I have to apologize I I was I was
tossed with having the trophy ready and
and then I I messed up my time and so I
sent the trophies to get polished and so
a friend of mine is actually bringing it
in and I apologize for this ladies and
gentlemen you you have to forgive me
hold on let me just see if like he said
he was going to be here by now and I'm
just trying to figure out where this is
held sorry sorry you know and yeah I'm
yes His Highness is looking at me I need
the trophy yeah the teacher the teachers
are here where are you now are you are
you coming bro don't worry I'm on my way
okay I'm just even though alright cool
so much appreciate
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
ladies and gentlemen the fastest man in
the world Lewis Hamilton
yo man I appreciate that Hamilton why'd
you take so long though are you doing
what was going on I know there's all
these speed bumps everywhere what like
you're killing me I said I need the
fastest man in Dubai and then you were
like cruisin with the police I thought
you were gonna be flying what happened I
got lost
I'm sorry I the navigation wasn't
working yes because they keep building
new things in Dubai man it's like they
caught the car start building thank you
for being here man Lewis Hamilton
everybody thank you so much I told a
little bit of a life I wanted to give it
to the fastest man in Dubai I would have
given it to a taxi driver and Dubai
would have been here in two seconds and
the trophy would have been fearing for
its life ladies and gentlemen it's time
for us to move on to the official
announcements as many of you know for
the past three years the winners names
have been announced in some of the most
spectacular ways it's one of the ways in
which the Varkey foundation has shown
that winning this award is a huge deal
you can imagine it's not exactly easy to
surpass an announcement from the Pope
or one from outer space which is why
this year the announcement is part of a
world record this is a really special
thing that the Varkey foundation and the
global teacher prize have put together
to announce it for the teachers in a way
that I think they will all appreciate
[Applause]
[Applause]
the largest hashtag formation by human
beings in the world ladies and gentlemen
I don't know if you heard the kids
screaming they shouted a name did you
hear what it was did someone hear what
it was was like a lot of kids his heart
so he has 7,000 kids there's a teacher
who heard it though there's one teacher
was like I heard it well in case you
didn't hear the name ladies and
gentlemen
Andrea Zafar aku
[Music]
hundreds of our operators
the winner of the 2018 Google teacher
prize
[Music]
ladies and gentlemen please welcome to
the stage His Highness Sheikh Mohammed
bin Rashid Al Maktoum vice president and
prime minister of the UAE and ruler of
Dubai and mr. sunny Varkey
[Music]
thank you one more time your highness
ladies and gentlemen for joining us and
congratulations we're gonna hear from
you in a moment on how you feel so take
a moment to compose your thoughts get
your speech ready because we actually
have a very special message for you your
highness
your excellencies ladies and gentlemen
as-salaam-alaikum good evening and on
behalf of everyone in the United Kingdom
my warmest congratulations to Andrea's
ephyra COO on winning the global teacher
prize 2018 to be chosen from more than
30,000 nominees in 173 countries is an
incredible achievement and it's a
fitting tribute to everything you've
done for your pupils at Albertan
Community School whether it's learning
how to greet pupils in each of their 35
first languages or organising
extracurricular activities around their
lives rather than the school day you
have shown enormous dedication and
creativity in your work being a great
teacher requires resilience ingenuity
and a generous heart these are the
qualities that you share with your
students every day so thank you for all
you have done and continue to do I would
also like to extend a huge thank you to
His Highness Sheikh Mohammed bin Rashid
Al Maktoum for his support of the
teaching profession and patronage of
this prize and congratulations to the
Varkey foundation for giving us such a
powerful celebration of the work of
teachers and your commitment to
education throughout the world finally
I'd like to say thank you to the other
finalists in this competition and to all
teachers everywhere your profession is
so important sparking curious young
minds
and educating the leaders scientists
artists and entrepreneurs of tomorrow
that's why as well as saluting Andria's
achievements the global teacher prize is
a tribute to all teachers so to our
winner her fellow finalists and every
dedicated teacher around the world thank
you and enjoy the rest of the evening
you heard from Prime Minister Teresa May
and now ladies and gentlemen let's hear
a few words from tonight's winner of
course you can deliver from any way you
want
[Applause]
Wow good evening everyone how are you
fine you ask me ask me
[Applause]
I've not practiced my speech so please
forgive me if I mess it up slightly but
first of all thank you to His Highness
Sheikh Mohammed bin Rashid Al Maktoum
thank you to sunny Varkey and the Varkey
foundation
[Applause]
I want to share this honor with my
fellow teachers and wonderful students
at Albertan Community School in Brent
London London no I think I know how it
feels now I also want to share this
honor with my fellow finalists
incredible people incredible
[Applause]
and all the teachers from all over the
world because tonight it's not about one
person it's about celebrating all the
teachers and recognizing the important
role they play in shaping the future for
our children I know the people who have
influenced me the most my mum my dad who
are somewhere here where are you mum
[Applause]
yeah
the Greek family have arrived also thank
you to my incredible rock my husband my
beautiful daughters Sofia and Maria and
my head teacher my boss who is in this
building today so thank you very much
for his support and also to all my
incredible friends who have been my my
inspiration the community where I teach
him Brent is beautifully diverse and
indeed is one of the most multicultural
communities in the world nearly half of
our residents were born outside the UK
and over a hundred different languages
are spoken by our students in our
schools for many of our students English
is not the main language spoken at home
it's also community where many of our
students unfortunately live in
challenging circumstances they have
tough lives they live in crowded homes
and sometimes there's a challenge for
them to find peace and a quiet place to
study others are unable to stay for
after-school activities because they are
carers or have to look after their
younger brothers and sisters whilst
their parents go to work what is amazing
is that whatever issues they are having
at home whatever is missing from their
life or causing them pain our school is
theirs
[Applause]
and I know that if our school could open
at six o'clock in the morning there
would be a queue of children waiting
outside at five o'clock in the morning
that's how phenomenal they are so the
most important thing that we can do as
teachers is to ensure that our schools
are safe havens we also have students
who have stable home lives and they
choose to come to our school this is
because our school celebrates diversity
and shapes them into real citizens who
accept and appreciate one another so
it's all the students all over the world
I say whatever your circumstances
whatever your troubles please know that
you have the potential to succeed in
whatever your dreams may be and that is
a right that nobody should take from you
yeah absolutely
[Applause]
since I was young my dream was to be in
art and textiles teacher I am proud to
be an art and textiles teacher the arts
have to fight for space in the
curriculum and for funding they are
often the first budgets to be cut this
is so wrong you can clap now
[Applause]
the arts teach students how to think
creatively which will be important for
the jobs they are likely to do when they
leave school they also teach resilience
and the perseverance can pay off for my
students the arts provide a sanctuary a
place where they can safely express
themselves and connect with their
identity we know that students who spend
more time on the arts can become more
successful at the rest of their studies
to my students are evidence of this
they thrive look at our results for a
curriculum that embraces the Arts
[Applause]
I just spent the most amazing few days
meeting with other phenomenal teachers
phenomenal teachers and they have come
from all over the world I am celebrating
this win with you and all our teachers
back home that is for all of us thank
you very much
[Applause]
one more time ladies and gentlemen the
2018 winner of the global teacher prize
[Applause]
and congratulations to our amazing
finalists
[Applause]
ladies and gentlemen please rise to
acknowledge His Highness Sheikh Mohammed
bin Rashid Al Maktoum vice president and
prime minister of the UAE and ruler of
Dubai thank you your highness
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you very much Leeds - Joan please
take a seat what a fantastic evening
this has been all of the clapping all of
the teachers lewis hamilton chased by
the police this was wonderful i can't
think of a better way to end it than
with our final performer for a final
closing i would like to introduce you
all to a very special guest at the age
of seven she was encouraged by her
grandmother to join a local church choir
and by the age of 28 she had won a
Golden Globe a Grammy and an Oscar he
has an inspiration for grandparents to
believe in their grandchildren or
children to believe in themselves for
all of us to strive to be the best and
just simply put on one hell of a show
ladies and gentlemen please welcome the
one and only Jennifer Hudson
[Music]
congratulations to our global teacher
prize finalists for 2018
you may now leave the stage and enjoy
the performance
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
this is remember the music I always like
to sing this song cuz it always reminds
me to stay true to my dreams and
aspirations and I think it encourages
others to do the same so no matter what
you do always remember why you do it
because we can only be great we're
passionate about what we do and saw this
song keeps me passionate about what I do
and that is why as cop remember the
music so I want to share with you
[Music]
follow me I'll teach you how to play
I'll be patient for you someone who's
patient with me Oh there'll always be a
chance that you could hit the room
[Music]
everybody can laugh and make it thank
you all but you don't have to give if
you leave me even when your time
[Music]
now in my past
[Music]
[Music]
sometimes you gotta face the music and
play by yourself but there always be a
chance that you could hit through
[Music]
it's not gonna lose
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Laughter]
yeah
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
this right here is my favorite song and
my absolute favorite song to sing and so
I want to share with you guys and I hope
you enjoy and it's called hallelujah and
we have Dave he loved her through a
secret huh
[Music]
David played and it pleased the shooter
[Music]
do ya
when it comes
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
fave for sure but you need haha Oh
[Music]
she tied you to her kitchen chair she
broke your throne and she could
[Music]
I know the face
I got above but all from love it's had a
shoot somebody who true yeah
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
teetee ladies and gentlemen one more
time Jennifer Hudson before we go we've
got the garlic coming up but I wanted to
invite Andrea back onto the stage please
and all of our special guests in the
front row could you join us we're gonna
we're gonna take a selfie real quick to
remember this moment so I have to do
this I qualify as a millennial come on
up everybody come on up and join us
let's see if we can get everybody in the
background oh you guys are all in it so
you may want to fix your ties
everybody's gonna be in this picture
look at this
[Music]
thank you one more time ladies gentlemen
congratulations Andrea thank you so much
to all of the teachers who've come out
thank you to every single educator that
joined us this evening we appreciate you
to every person who traveled here from
across the world to join us tonight
thank you so much for making this a
success congratulations to all of the
finalists we're gonna be kicking off the
garlic shortly so please lady to them
and enjoy yourselves make your way down
the red carpet and thank you for joining
us at the global teacher prize 2018